hey 42 here he loves me he loves me not
is a simple yes-or-no game played by
English girls but did you know that the
French version fu Li L AM Marguerite has
five different options with positive
responses ranging from the lukewarm he
loves mere bits to the intense he loves
me crazily the French language is a
myriad of words and phrases concerning
the love with plenty making their way
into other languages rendezvous menage
tois femme fatale and more so what makes
the French so romantic
is it something in the air or is it
something in the language itself can the
language we speak control the way we
think it may sound like science fiction
but people have actually believed this
to some extent for hundreds of years and
there have been studies that show that
the language we speak can directly
influence the way we see and experience
the world around us linguistic
relativity is the idea another languages
structure affects its speaker's
worldview the phrase was coined by an
American linguist called Benjamin Lee
Whorf who famously studied the Hopi in
the 1930s a Native American tribe that
live in Arizona this is why you'll often
hear linguistic relativity referred to
as warfield ism Woolf wrote that the
Hopi treated time very differently to
much of the rest of the world and
suggested that this was reflected in and
influenced by their language he used the
Hopi as an example of how the language
we speak can influence the way we think
he discovered that the Hopi have no
concept of time because their language
contains no words used to describe it
such as future and the word time itself
in English so when a Hopi woman breaks
his husband because I told you to skin
that da yesterday he could simply reply
sorry love
I don't know what yesterday is to be
fair this isn't quite what he discovered
what work is often mistakenly said to
suggest that the Hopi have no concept of
time
whatsoever whereas he actually found
that the tribe have no general notion or
intuition of time as a smooth flowing
continuum in which everything in the
universe proceeds at equal rate out of a
future through the present into a past
the hope he also didn't seem to have
words for units of time in the way that
we have minutes hours and days so did
they experience the world differently if
they didn't have the linguistic tools to
describe time as a concept where their
brains wired in a different way to ours
because of the language they used to
think and speak whilst Worf laid the
groundwork for this train of thought he
never had the chance to really
experiment and test it as he died in
1941 leaving behind several and
published papers which were taken up by
friends and colleagues it was left up to
Roger Brown and Erik Lenin Berg to test
a theory of linguistic relativity
through experiments with color brown and
Lenin Berg tested English speakers
alongside natives of the indigenous Zuni
tribe to see how well they could
remember certain colors they found the
Zuni people who don't have words to
differentiate between different colors
for example between yellow and orange
struggles to remember these colors
correctly meanwhile the English speakers
who had words for these different shades
found remembering them and identifying
them later in the experiments much
easier more recent experimentation on
the same phenomena has equally shown
that Russian speakers you have different
words for light and dark blue are far
more adept are quickly identifying
different shades than English speakers
our scientists have also been able to
note surprise in the brain of Russian
speakers as a color display shifts from
light to dark blue to them the color has
fundamentally changed whereas English
speakers lack the same surprise since
all AC is blue getting a little darker
our brains will show the same surprise
for red shifting to orange since we
actually do have separate words for
those two colors
through these tests proved that the
brains of the Zuni people English
speakers and Russians are all wired
differently
there certainly appears to be some sort
of link between linguistics and
cognitive skills
it seems that learning more words for
colors made your brain better at telling
those colors apart the theory of
linguistic relativity has fallen in and
out of fashion over the years from the
1960s to the 1980s most linguists
subscribed to the theory of the
universal grammar that there are innate
structural rules to languages and as any
humans will develop languages with the
same basic properties like having nouns
and distinguishing certain colors that's
right we're back to colors linguist love
using colors in our experiments since it
provides a link between perception and
language using something scientists can
easily control they can measure colors
by their wavelengths to ensure they're
precise about any given shade this time
Brent Berlin and Paul K where the
scientists looking at how different
languages describe colors they wanted to
find out if all languages approached
colors in the same way was their
universality about the way we as a human
race talked about color
by studying dozens of different
languages they found that there were NH
restrictions on how many basic color
terms or categories a language could
have they identified eleven
distinguishable colors that aren't too
narrow in their usage such as blonde
which we only use to describe hair and
beer or turquoise which is just a bluey
green the eleven basic color categories
they discovered across all languages are
white black red green yellow blue brown
purple pink orange and gray they also
discovered that new colors evolved
within different languages in a familiar
unpredictable patter
Languages would always focus on the same
colors first as they evolved for
instance every language has words for
dark and light that's hardly surprising
and these two terms eventually become
black and white as other colors are
separated out but did you know that if a
language only has three colors the third
color to be added to the lexicon will
always be red the fourth and fifth
colors will always be green and yellow
though these two can be in either order
and the language with six colors will
always add blue to the mix if every
language adds color names in this order
doesn't that suggest that color
recognition is something hardwired into
our brains and part of our very nature
as opposed to the linguist relativity
school which suggests it's the opposite
ie how we describe colors dictates how
we perceive them these discoveries were
key to the Universalist period of
linguistics but there's not much
scientists love more than reigniting old
arguments and so in the 80s and 90s
linguistic determination came roaring
back into fashion just like dungarees
unfortunately this new more low key idea
of linguistic relativity proposed that
language is a key to culture clearly the
Vega your statements the harder it is to
disprove but this latest version of the
old theory came back with some more
shiny new examples especially from
George Lakoff who heavily studied the
metaphors used by certain languages for
instance like I've noticed that in
English much of the language around time
treats it similarly to money in that
time can be bought spent invested and so
on Lakoff argued that these metaphors
shape how we think about time and that's
our approach to it might be different if
we spoke a language where time wasn't
equated to money in this way
so can the words we use change our
fundamental understanding of something
like color or time it's an idea that's
explored in the story of your life by
Ted Chang which was made into the 2016
sci-fi film arrival now a quick spoiler
alert is needed here because it's a
great film definitely worth a watch in
both the book and the film a linguist
learns the language of an alien race
called Hector Potts named so for their
seven limbs as she learns the language
of the hab demands the linguists
perception of time as being linear
changes as well her brain is rewired by
the language she now knows and
consequently she is able to see into the
future in arrival the linguist
eventually works out why the hepta pods
have arrived on earth in the first place
their language is a tool that they have
gifted to the human race in return for a
favor
the Hector pods will need 3,000 years in
the future so how realistic is the idea
that learning a new language can
completely rewire our brains in granters
cognitive skills that seem downright
supernatural or magical this extreme
version of linguistic relativity is
generally agreed to be well beyond the
realm of plausibility
but scintilla we've encountered aliens
and learns they're potentially
life-changing language who knows how
abouts the more down to Planet Earth
idea that language changes the way we
think about the world around us in
subtle but impactful ways this is less
controversial and it's pretty easy to
find everyday examples of this like how
time is equated with money in English
several foreign languages provide
interesting opportunities to look at
this effect through gender the English
language doesn't really have grammatical
gender in English we only differentiate
between the gender of people and animals
with his her him
and she and that's just fine on a sort
of personal note I'll never be
comfortable accepting that they as a
singular pronoun is grammatically
correct despite the fact it's now
entered the vernacular but many other
languages have genders for all their
nouns in German spoon fork and knife are
masculine feminine and neuter
respectively the logic for this while
some nouns do you have a thought process
behind their gender like how many
flowers in German are feminine there
often isn't any logic at all so just
thinking about inanimate objects as
having genders influence house speakers
of those languages think and perceive
their world you bet it does a 2002 study
looked at how native German and Spanish
speakers described certain objects the
objects the researchers had chosen were
carefully selected so that they were of
opposite grammatical gender in each
language like a key which is masculine
in German and feminine in Spanish when
they asked the participants to describe
keys the German natives use adjectives
like hard heavy and jagged while Spanish
because Ford keys were intricate little
and lovely the word bridge is your way
around it's feminine in German and sure
enough German speakers described bridges
has beautiful elegant and slender while
Spanish speakers felt they were strong
sturdy and towering what's more these
unconscious biases seemed to extend
beyond the confines of their native
tongues since the entire study was
conducted in English a language which
all the participants were fluent in
what's more the researchers found that
the participants didn't even need to
speak or read to draw upon these biases
when they were shown two pictures one of
a person and one of an object the
participants rated the pictures as more
similar to each other when the gender of
the person
master grammatical gender of the object
so any Spanish speakers watching this
will presumably think I look much more
like a bridge that aqui whilst Germans
will say it's giveaway around I don't
know which is more flattering so if
language can influence the way we see
the world than the objects within it
it's human nature to then ask what can
we do with this information and
depending on what sort of person you are
things can basically go two ways from
here down the scary route or the nice
one the scary route takes us into the
realm of dystopian societies something
that was perhaps most famously explored
by George Orwell in his novel 1984
despite being written in the 1940s
before much of the research we've
already mentioned 1984 goes hard on the
idea of linguistic relativity from its
use of news speak the bastardized
version of english that big brother
under the oppressive state used to
control her subjects Newspeak is the
only language spoken at 1984 it is
carefully controlled by the state it has
a simplified and restricted vocabulary
which aims to limit freedom of thought
this makes it almost impossible for its
speakers to articulate negative thoughts
about their government or their own
circumstances by only giving the
population a small set of simple
unambiguous words to communicate how
happy they are Newspeak removes any
opportunity for creative indirect
anti-establishment forms imagine trying
to criticize something but not knowing
any negative words this was a struggle
like characters in 1984 found themselves
in all thanks to the influence that
their language had on them if all this
sounds frightfully reminiscent of what
the political correctness Warriors are
trying to do right now that's because
it's exactly the same and yes it's
terrifying
of course language changing the way we
think could also be a good thing as well
there have been several languages
created with the aim of providing a
speakers with a different more positive
experience one language is Logan an
abbreviation of logical language that
was developed in the 1950s by dr. James
Cook Brown Braun wanted to create a
language that was so different from
natural languages that simply learning
it would force people to think in a
different way Lachlan was amongst the
first logical languages and spawned a
similar spin-off called Lodge bun with
the same aims and it appears to have
worked since speakers have Lodge button
rapport improvements in logical thinking
as they immersed themselves within the
language Lodge man is also easy to learn
and easy for computers to translate
since any word in lodz one only has one
meaning compare that to English where a
word like get can mean receive become
understands move catch and learn whereas
load one has the word kappachu which is
defined as gets procures acquires
obtains accepts from source previous
possessor not implied sure sounds useful
if you are wanting to be ultra specific
about your meaning but I'm not sold for
me part of the beauty of the English
language is its ambiguity and that's
what makes conversing in it reading it
and speaking it so damn interesting
although we talk I believe is really
interesting as you would expect it's all
very logical each word is built from its
equivalent in the world's six most
popular languages English Mandarin Hindi
Spanish Arabic and Russian take the word
for mother Mamta and you can see it does
indeed sound a bit like mother
mouki Mon Madre um and mamma
another example comes from linguist and
writer Suzette's Hayden elegan who
created the feminist language Laden that
would make it easier to express a female
worldview she wanted to shape a culture
where women could more easily express
their views through unambiguous
statements the idea behind this was that
speakers of la hoddan could clearly
express not only what they were saying
but the trustworthiness of their
statements - this is done through an
evidence particle a short addition to
the end of statements that reflects how
confident the speaker is in what she has
said el djem wanted to stop women from
constantly having to respond I know I
said that but I meant this when men
questions their statements like a
linguistic version of the point-of-view
gun from Hitchhiker's Guide sounds
positively terrifying pursuing the idea
that speaking a certain language could
improve was isn't a pipe dream there are
existing examples of natural languages
that have honed their speaker's skills
for instance googy yamasa an Australian
Aboriginal language is famous for two
things the first is that it gave us the
word kangaroo though not in the way that
the common myth tells us the urban
legend goes that Captain Cook and his
crew encountered the animal and asked
the locals what it was the aboriginals
replied kangaroo
apparently meaning I don't understand
you unforeseen corrected this
misconception through their studies of
the googy humor fur people but the story
continues to be told to this day the
second thing that has brought googy
humor fur into the public consciousness
is that its speakers commonly used to
cardinal directions of north south east
and west rather than using the
egocentric terms like left-to-right
forwards and backwards that were used to
they don't just use these for giving
directions and navigating either your
left leg could be your southwestern leg
depending on the way you're standing now
this may well make some things more
difficult it certainly makes the
hokey-pokey a fair bit harder to sing
but speaking the language has its
judges as well as a result of using
cardinal directions all the time
speakers of the language have a
remarkable sense of direction and almost
always know exactly which direction
they're facing the same is true for
speakers of cuckoo tire another
Aboriginal language in Queensland its
speakers need to know which direction
they're facing because this informs a
direction they understand time to
flowing if I asked you to draw a
timeline of your life most of you would
start with your birth at the left and
progress through time from left to right
the Kuk tire would arrange event running
from east to west regardless of which
direction they were facing if they were
facing west ty would flow directly away
from them turn 180 degrees and it would
be coming straight at them instead
having a number system forms the basis
of so much of modern life without
mathematics
there could be no engineering no
computers no YouTube to watch this video
on but some languages don't actually
have number systems at least not in the
way we do ask them to count a group of
objects and you may not get a precise
number just many without the ability to
calculate the exact quantities or entire
way of life as we know it would be
impossible and as much as this gap in
one's language restricts thinking it's
equally possible that we haven't yet
unlocked many other realms of
possibilities simply because we don't
have the words for them yet the 7,000
languages spoken around the world have
gotten us this far
who knows what words and languages will
be invented in the future that will
allow us to conceptualize things that
are currently impossible that may be the
next step in language affecting how we
all think for the better thanks for
watching have you ever felt like the
sound of your voice is holding you back
from expressing yourself forging strong
relationships or furthering your career
truth is your voice can do great things
all you need is the right voice coach to
unlock its full potential recently I
spent time with in
my opinion the best voice coach in the
industry Richard de bretagne to help me
find the right sound for my upcoming
audio book most voice coach's force you
to speak like the Queen but Richard
helps you to enhance the natural warmth
and enchanting tone of your existing
voice in just a few hours of bespoke
one-to-one license over Skype Richard
may be the best but his lessons cost the
same as a few cups of coffee visit hello
voice over comm now link in the
description to book and secure your
lessons before they sell out and
exclusively for a short time Richard is
offering my viewers 20% off if you
mention the coupon code 42 if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me by joining the 42 Club
here on YouTube by clicking the join
button below or heading on over to
patreon you can also get your hands on a
first edition signed copy of my new book
sticker flock in it by heading on over
to unbound publishing and pre-ordering
your copy today and thanks to hello
voice over comm for sponsoring this
video